Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P I recently appeared on
a program called The Trigonometry where I went to
on one with some right wing wing British hosts.
And at a certain point during that, they
brought up the question of the definition
of a woman. One of our viewers didn't
like that. It was me and two other dudes
sitting around talking about the definition
of a woman. Listen to what she had to say.
Speaker 2: David is Susan from Chicago? Yeah.
Speaker 5: I'm with you right now.
Speaker 2: I just watched a video or part of
video of you with two other guys sitting around
discussing what is the woman, what's wrong
with you and what role does it make? Yes.
I mean, seriously, dude, I'm with you every
day and I'm just like, I'm my mind is blown.
Do with it what you will piece out by.
Speaker 1: Listen,
I'm just I can't help that I am male, okay? And
I can't help that I was invited on to a show.
That show has two male hosts, and
then they brought up the topic of a
definition of a woman. So I don't think it's
the same as when we say, hey, here is a panel
of exclusively 70 year old white men deciding what
the rules on abortion should be from a legislative
standpoint. I'm with you there that where are the
women's voices? What? It doesn't make any sense.
I was just on a show and the topic came up.
Okay, so let's take it easy. Let's not go. Let's,
let's not go crazy here. We have such a
great bonus show for you today. Number one,
big oil is cashing in. And we're going to talk
about surging big oil profits where they come
from. It's not as simple as the price of oil is
up and so they make more money. It's actually
more complicated than that. And we'll talk about
that on today's bonus show. Secondly, the Taliban,
which some on the left and right like to say
is a much more moderate influence within Islam,
is now ordering women to be covered, head to
toe in public at all times, period. So not
exactly the progressive inflows that some were
hoping for from the Taliban. And then lastly,
it it's insane that this is actually becoming an
issue, but it is the death penalty for those who
get abortions is becoming a major issue in
a Republican runoff in the state of Texas.
I've mentioned this once before, I think it was a
few weeks ago, and it's growing as an issue. And
we're going to talk about it on today's bonus
show. Get access to the bonus show so easily
by signing up at join Packman dot com.
Speaker 4: Oh the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Alex Jones does not like
the bonus show. He finds it predatory.
Speaker 4: That is a frickin predator right there.
Speaker 1: I love the bonus show and many of our
members around the world do. So I encourage you to
sign up at join Pacman dot com. And then lastly,
remember, if you're absolutely not willing to
sign up today, Monday, May 30, Memorial Day,
a lot of a lot of EMS, we are doing a one day
insane membership blowout. The reason I'm doing
it on a federal holiday is if my accountant
knew about this, he would never let me do it.
If my lawyer knew about this, he would
drop me as a client. We are doing
a massive membership blowout on May 30th. I
expect to run out of memberships. And if you
want to be notified about that, you can get on
my mailing list at join pacman at I'm sorry. No
at David Pakman dot com. David Pakman dot com.
Get on the mailing list. Get the bonus show.
I will see you then or otherwise. We will
be back here and together again tomorrow.